so the person that I want a couple up
with is Plus this so the boy that I want
a couple up with is Jared right now I
think I need to do what's best for me
I choose to remove myself from the villa
and I hope you guys understand two
Islanders had to end their sandy search
for love and when one faced rejection
she rose above this is love after the
island
[Music]
hey sexy beaches welcome to love after
the island your official love Island
recap show I'm a lauren zima here to
spill all the tropical tea on this
fourth week of love island airing only
on CBS and CBS all access and guess what
love island fanatics love island has
been renewed that is right
CBS's sexy summer hit we'll be back for
a second season though for now we still
have to see who can weather the storm to
talk about it all joining me now in our
cozy Cabana - fan favorites fresh out of
Fiji castle barnett and katrina de
Marana
are here I have so many questions for
you guys welcome okay when I just said
hey sexy beaches you guys were laughing
why is this something that you said on
the show I'm so happy to meet you guys
Cashel I have so many feels for you I
just so much emotion on the show Katrina
I have so many questions for you about
West and after this past week we are
gonna get into it all especially that
love island triangle we're calling it
the love island Bermuda Triangle of the
week Weston Emily and Kyra so to quickly
catch everyone up - Lynne Katrina you
were sent home by your fellow Islanders
then if the power was put in the lady's
hands newcomer Emily chose Weston moving
cutie Kelsey to self exit and we also
saw Eric and Anton depart after Kira
coupled up with Jared over Eric and Kara
went for a over and time I mean you guys
are the perfect people to have in this
week because Weston and Kira are very
much the talk of the islands and that's
true
- it's just like that I can try there
your exes like is this a little weird at
all
a little bit yeah everything's unfold
all right well castle I want to go back
and we're gonna get into the emotions
with you because your uh your goodbyes
with Tara was painful and she was left
in tears like literally like what it's
not like this just threw me I feel like
I lost the best friend I can honestly
say that I love the kid you know and we
know it just doesn't feel right being
here without him yeah I watched that
episode and like yeah the ex everybody's
crying I mean and when it was happening
it felt sad it's sad to not be with
everybody and see but were you surprised
that Kira pick Derek over you and then
the second you left she's in tears she's
saying she loves you she misses you and
she kind of lost her feelings for Erik
what did you think seeing the aftermath
of your goodbyes
honestly care and I have like a super
deep connection like we saw into each
other's Souls like immediately on
meeting each other I mean don't get me
wrong it felt good to see her like so
upset but I mean we didn't talk the last
three days so it was really kind of
mixed emotion because I feel bad that
she's going through it but I'm also kind
of like come on girl love you too you
know like do you still have feelings for
her yeah like absolutely of course 100%
I mean right now you're less than a week
out of the island it's been weird I
honestly feel like a piece of me is
missing that's kind of everybody though
like leaving you just miss everybody's
energy and you got so close to everybody
and honestly getting back I was like I
can't not watch I have to watch because
one I miss everybody so it's like these
are my friends and I want to be with
them but then two I'm also just like
what's going on kid like what's she
doing you know and she's been like the
center of everything so it's it's been
like very intense why did you want to
give that gift to her of something that
seemed really sentimental to you a
friend of mine gave me these little
backs to a guitar tuning peg and I made
jewelry out of them and I've been giving
them out kind of slowly to friends of
mine that are really special to me and
also how we have a musical connection
and Kara just I mean fit that bill to a
tee and that was my last one like that
was like mine you know that was mine of
the six and it just felt so right she
just needed it and just our connection
you know it was so pure if Kira winds up
single at the end of all this are you
reaching out to her to see if you guys
can make something happen regardless of
if Kara comes out single or not I'm
gonna reach out there because there's so
much love there and so much good energy
like we're gonna make music together
like we talked about and maybe more ways
than one oh wow
all Katrina you were coupled up with
Weston at one point and I want to know
what was going through your mind
watching the way that Weston was
treating Kelsey after Emily came into
the house I was a little bit surprised
because you know like all the girls were
saying he's so good at making you feel
like you can be yourself and be open and
he's once he makes me feel special or
whatever
and then you know you told me the same
thing but he told Kelsey where was like
no if a girl were to come in it would
mean nothing to me like I want to focus
on you and I or whatever knows I get
gold and then Kelsey comes in and then
the girls go on that less thing to come
back and he's totally all up on her and
you know like we weren't really talking
after that anymore
I'm gonna pick her again the thing is
Weston is super pure of heart he's not
manipulating anybody yeah he's just like
a primal man he's just like going out
like it's like huh like me and like I
feel good about this and I'm going for
it you got it ring the fire you got to
bring the heat I got I get it for your
pile oh man and don't say things that
you don't mean don't say things like
right that's really what it comes down
to
well Kelsey ended up self exiting I mean
watching Weston ping-pong between trying
to comfort Kelsey and do the right thing
at her saying no go comfort Emily it was
such a crazy scene captivating should
kelsey have left i don't think she
should have left i think she could have
found someone it sucks
i understood why she stepped down she
was falling in love Weston for sure like
she was really really hurt and I totally
understand why she did what she did I
appreciate it when she just said look if
you're clearly not into me then I'm
gonna go I get exploring other options
but if you're clearly picking somebody
else over me I'm not gonna fight
somebody for you I get back all right so
let's talk triangles I have never seen
anything like this on television love
island gave us a throuple of Attraction
Weston was into Keira and Emily Hiro was
into Weston and Emily and Emily was into
Weston and Keira let's take a look
so rewind to first week you would have
pursued me more that
and obviously cash my boy wasn't gonna
be like yo do you think you didn't
pursue me because cash was your boy
throughout time 100% Emily she's a cutie
like girl eyes yeah she straight up my
type she seems like a really cool chick
she's hot as hell too so this morning
and Kyra pulls me she's like I'm
interested in getting to know you and
I'm attracted to you to me I'm not
opposed to no Kara more but I know that
I have a connection with you I like you
100%
so Weston and Emily have ended up
together but were you guys surprised to
watch Weston and Kyra tell each other
that state always felt something or did
you sense that when you were there I
mean I knew that they were like BFF we
all knew that Weston literally said if
it wasn't for you Cashel that he would
have gone for Kira that caught me
alright for me none of this surprised me
whatsoever why not we're also connected
all we have to do is gossip like
everybody in the villa knew that Kieran
Weston had a little song by each other
okay absolutely but they felt stronger
feelings and like wanted to explore
other things more here is all about
trying all these different things out
and now we're seeing Weston obviously is
like one to try different things
uh-huh it makes sense better just try it
go Oh probably that's right Katrina what
do you think of the way Weston is
handling all this there is a pattern to
how he's going about each new woman that
walks into the villa and he has said the
same things to each woman as well okay I
understand that well all the ladies
ended up turning on Weston calling out
whether or not he was for real let's
take a look I think everybody kind of
threw me under the bus and I just like
to know the truth so I can kind of
explain it like it doesn't really matter
what we think at the end of the day she
literally asked us what our thoughts
were on you and no one skewed anything
everyone just said with our experiences
have been the reason why I think it's so
easy for you to say these things because
this is like the end of the experience
and it's like you could have easily said
this about Cal so you could have easily
said this about Craig you know but right
now do I believe what you're saying no I
don't like I just feel like it's not
really genuine you just saying this
because it's the end of the experience
like I just got backstabbed on something
that I actually care about and now so if
you care about it then maybe you should
fight for it so there's
saying this is what people think about
me I'm going home I know you're the girl
100% but with what people are saying
about me doesn't add up to who I
actually am and I'm not about to sit
there and have someone say that I'm fake
you have your guys you know that you're
a genuine person you know that you're
genuine and I know that you're genuine
even though like I am a little bit
confused right now because of everything
that's going on like I still really do
care about you and I don't want you to
feel like you're not like one here
because I want you here it was
interesting to me that Weston wound up
in this spot with Emily they're a new
couple they've gone through a lot of ups
and downs already and this whole thing
really spiraled really quickly so let me
ask you guys it's Kira responsible for
all this
well I'm like no not at all
I think honestly everybody's at this
point emotionally exhausted like if you
haven't gotten in a couple that you feel
strong with like it makes a lot of sense
I'm not surprised that things are
getting into that spiral zone and going
really really fast I mean things go fast
in there yeah and so when everybody like
new girl comes in and everybody sprung
on her and everybody wants everyone to
succeed and find something I'm not
surprised that there's all just this
like intimacy flying around if anybody
just Emily you know Emily's apparently
the fire like she's beautiful it's
intimacy sparks everywhere
I kind of felt like Kira was this woman
who pretty much everybody seemed to have
a thing for now Emily's maybe taking
that title do you think Kira feels
threatened by Emily seem less yeah yeah
to some degree like a little fan yeah I
mean I saw the little looks watching it
back like when Kristin came in and like
Kristin and I would talk
yeah I saw Kira kind of you know really
yeah
if Kira came to Weston and just
straight-up said I want us to try
something out here would he say goodbye
to Emily at this point I feel like if
the girls did not call him out like that
and him wanting to go home because
everyone turned their back he probably
would but I don't know I feel like now
he's like oh I shouldn't do that because
it's just gonna get worse for me and you
know he doesn't want more trouble and
more drama I feel like right now
probably not that's just my best night
that last scene he looks shook that's
what I'm saying like he's not gonna do
anything now all right well let me ask
you guys right now who really is
genuinely looking for love the most
genuine person in the house guy and girl
kara and Ray okay I think I think Kara
Kara was like looking you know I love
bunny she's always hoppin and she's
trying to find her fields maybe she
knows what she wants and that's why it's
easy for her to just move on to the next
person like she knows that's not what
she wanted and people see if some people
may see it as like oh she's just trying
to hook up with every guy and no like
this girl actually knows what she wants
and long-term and everything
that's why Carol was like we're going to
the hideaway all right on Thursday night
the Islanders learns that one couple
would get a sandy sayonara based on your
votes the pair's in jeopardy are Weston
and Emily
Damon and I sada Weston Emily have
already faced a lot of problems on the
island so the question is will they last
and who will go home what do you guys
think who do you think's going home
Weston's up Weston and Emily are gone oh
absolutely
I mean it was easy to see with us but I
think America in the same way as the
Islanders it's like if they're not
trying as a couple you're out I can like
respect that process you know
fascinating to watch so will they get
kept around just because we want to
watch what's gonna happen bags I think
that that was why Kira and Jared were
voted on cuz they're obviously not
happening well Kira is like she's the
fire she's goin like there's so much
going on there you can care what
surprise doesn't seem like they've
talked at all clearly Alex all right now
it's time to hear from our dearly
departed the Islanders who left without
love a goodbye that's more salty than
sexy here's what they exclusively told
and Entertainment Tonight I feel very
confident am I
and I think I made a death best decision
for me and I think I'm leaving here with
absolutely no regrets and I think that
I'm leaving here on the best foot I did
what I needed to do and I think I meet
as many connections as possible you know
I try to find a connection and things
didn't work out and I trusted my god I
stay true to myself and that's all you
can do at the end of the day I'm not
sure really how I'm feeling right now
it's still kind of like processing all
that and the being of the night I
thought I was pretty like safe but I
love all that hopefully we can all like
link up on the outside and have fun I'm
feeling okay about I'm very intuitive
with energy I kind of anticipated
tonight being my last night definitely
really happy about the experience I got
to jump in the ocean for the first time
meet a bunch of beautiful people from
the inside home and I mean Emily I mean
save my number in case you ain't the one
you know what I mean
you're a bad one Oh Missy hello Eric
seems pretty confident oh that's Eric
man oh well we also have a message from
a special someone on the sand a familiar
voice welcome to love island hey et hey
my favorite host ever Lauren Zima what's
going on guys Matthew Hoffman Here I am
the official voice and narrator of love
island u.s.a it's 3:00 a.m. here in Fiji
and I get in at about 1 a.m. and we
start writing the show and recording the
show and we are done at about 10:30 a.m.
and then it goes out to you guys by 1:00
p.m. I think it's live with you guys in
the East Coast so the turnaround is
pretty insane it's awesome to bring you
guys a show that you get day of so what
happens here in Fiji happens back in the
States
you guys see it in real time I have a
show - right it's we have a couple more
hours so what you guys see tonight is
when I snuck off to the video so thank
you guys for watching Lauren you are the
best and we will see you guys soon
you and I know each other we will be
working together on different stuff
before he's the sweetest guy
Oh Matthew we love you thank you and I
love he's such a professional he set up
a shot with a palm tree behind him he
knew I'm gonna give you guys the Fiji
guys yeah all right guys we have
officially filled our love tank for this
week tune in though Friday night to find
out which couple leaves the island
ladies man Weston and his latest love
Emily or the more long-standing a man
and
Asada and our special thanks to cache of
our net and Katrina de Marana for being
here and for letting us in on your
journey to find love all right tune in
to love island five nights a week only
on CBS and CBS L access and join us here
every Friday for our weekly keiki to
dish on all the major moments we will be
joined by celebrity guests and feature
exclusive content you won't want to miss
plus you can find us on entertainment
tonight's 24/7 digital streaming service
ET live at ET live.com or via the ET
live app and speaking of apps do not
forget to download the official love
island app to help you slide into
summers hottest show from the comfort of
your own home from our cozy Cabana here
in california i'm lauren zima thanks for
watching guys stay cool sexy beaches
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Applause]